how do you make 7 an even number
by taking the s out evolution in mobile
phones in recent years
has significantly changed how we
perceive things
we are definitely going to see even more
advancements in the coming years
but one thing that has remained constant
for a very long time is
that we still have to dial a fixed
number of digits
for making a phone call and this leads
us to a curious question
why do telephone numbers have fixed
number of digits
how is it decided and how do we get
different possibilities
let's understand that in this q episode
of q
box
[Music]
the number of digits is generally
dependent on two things
first one being the population count of
a country
and the second one the number of mobile
devices that the population holds
to make it simple let's consider india
as our example
india has fixed its mobile number to 10
digits excluding the country code
such that each and every mobile number
is unique
that means no two individuals will have
the same mobile number
otherwise imagine the chaos it would
lead to
right there now why ten digits only
why not 7 or 8 or 11 digits for that
matter
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
the answer lies in simple math that is
counting of digits and what do i mean by
this
it's time to unravel here we have digits
from 0 to 9 with us
it is very obvious that using these
digits
we have to form different mobile numbers
also we need to note that each and every
mobile number
should be unique so tell me in how many
ways can we arrange these 10 digits
to get our desired results remember
we're only interested in the total count
of the mobile numbers
and not the actual arrangement of the
digits
so can we do it manually no don't even
think of doing that
you may end up losing a lot of your time
and energy
then how do we approach this let's begin
with the basics consider we only had
four digits for a mobile number
which means that we can select any four
digits out of the ten digits available
now tell me
in how many different ways can we form
four digit mobile numbers
it's time to solve this interesting
puzzle let's make
four slots like this these four slots
together will form a single mobile
number
let's begin with the first slot in how
many ways can we fill the first
slot well we have 10 digits
at our disposal thus we can select any
of those
to fill our first slot
that's right we can say that the first
slot
can be filled in ten different ways
having filled the first slot in how many
ways can we fill the second
slot with well here many of us would
think that if the first slot was filled
with one of these 10 digits
then we're left with only nine digits
for the second slot
is that correct nope that's not true
remember our goal is to form mobile
numbers where the digits can be repeated
that means the second slot can have the
same digit
as that in the first slot for example
if we have a digit 1 in our first slot
then the same digit 1 can be in our
second slot as well
if we have digit 0 here then we can have
it here as well
so now can you tell me in how many ways
can we fill the second slot
yes in 10 different ways
if you've understood the logic can you
answer this
in how many ways can we fill the third
slot
perfect in 10 different ways and the
same logic holds good for the fourth
slot as well
so we filled each slot in 10 different
ways
first slot in 10 ways and the second in
ten ways and the third in ten ways
and the fourth two in ten ways notice
i've used
and here that's where the rule of
counting comes into picture
and means multiplication to know more
about
counting and similar concepts head to
our course
on permutations and combinations
now getting back 10 multiplied by 10 is
100 multiplied by 10 is one thousand and
when one thousand is multiplied by ten
we get ten thousand ten thousand
different mobile numbers
this is nowhere close to india's current
population
its population is close to 1.4 billion
and is constantly increasing as well
so having a four-digit mobile number is
out of the question what if we consider
a mobile number comprising of five
digits
after calculation we get one hundred
thousand different possibilities
so mobile number with five digits is
definitely
not an option and the results we get for
mobile numbers
with 6 7 8 or even 9 digits
are also something that do not satisfy
the demands of
india's current population so what
should we do next
let's check for mobile numbers
comprising of 10 digits
after doing the math the result obtained
is this
huge number this is nothing else but
10 billion different possibilities of
mobile numbers
here we go and that is why 10 digit
mobile numbers are considered
as a standard for now in india
now you may say that many users use
multiple sim cards
what do we do then no worries at all
even if everyone uses two sim cards the
mobile numbers used will be around
3 billion if you look at the number of
mobile numbers at our disposal
we would still have around 7 billion
more in our bag for use
hence we do not have to worry at all
now let me tell you an interesting fact
japan has opted
11 digits as their standard mobile
number even though their population
is much lower than that of india
so who makes this decision
it's the department of telecommunication
of a particular nation
that has the decision-making power and
indian telecom department has opted for
10 digit mobile numbers
as a standard now what would happen
if all the 10 billion possibilities are
exhausted
is it even possible in the coming years
with the growth of population we cannot
predict that as of now
only time will tell but what do you
think
this is your q box to explore one of the
options we could think of
is that maybe in the future we can
completely switch onto something like
virtual ids to make phone calls instead
of using cellular networks
let us know your opinions too to be a
part of a massive learning
community don't forget to subscribe to
our channel
do share this video with your friends
and family
happy learning
you